walter ich lag da kein werk ein prima
bei dir das ist echt so am haken dass
man jedoch regen regen regen an
also hier ist regen bei mir ganzen ob
tief ein regen aus ställen ehrlich klar
dabei entstand was ihnen in den dialog
der regen der nicht echt tierisch aber
ich finde irgendwie wenn wir das lieber
richtig setzen
die grafikeinstellungen titels
jetzt habe ich nur die animationen
ausgemacht läuft noch aber man hört es
nicht mehr lief nicht mehr im keller
hatten
das tut ihnen nichts mehr rechnung
ausstellen ja aber wo hast du dir dann
ausgestellt optionen grafikeinstellungen
und einem wetter oft ja gut ich habe das
bei den partikeln gemacht hat ich möchte
klaus gestellt habe dann kam nur so
komisch pletscher dings auf dem boden
obwohl es gar nicht geregelt hat die
hälfte des weges vor mir und es ist
stockfinster
watson jüngst an
ich bin mit und skelette alter wie
solchen das schaffen
ich schätze zu fressen jungen da kommt
ein krieg und ich schmeiß moment wenn
die aus schwertberg okay
das ist in der tat ziemlich doof wenn
ich brauch irgendwelche schweine hallo
ich mache mir erstmal ein jetpack wieder
ein neues tab a100 möchte anders als
wunder
3m batteries ein kupferkabel und holz
habe ich noch mein glaube ich nicht ich
hab zu tun
ich habe nichts ich kann nicht mal die
hälfte bin ich meine waffe war gerade
noch gegner wie weg spiele scheiße so
noch andere spinnen
ich keine batterien
ich bin hinter mir das ist doch
verschwunden
ich koche es mehr denn je ja ich will
mir die spitze gleich wieder
weggeschmissen
hahaha ich muss das immer wegschmeißt
weil ich keinen platz haben
ich bin mehr user meter von uns entfernt
meinte der spitze klier wegschmeißt
pazifik
so dass auch noch fressen ich hätte
jetzt vorschlag gesagt dass wir mal kurz
pennen gehn oder so ich bin zu hause
jetzt habe ich darf alles leben sofort
sich kurz mein leben
aufladen lassen so 300 meter sind noch
ich glaube vor stellt sich wie
weitermacht baue ich mir jetzt ein
bisschen ein haus oder so auf versuchen
ihn bald die dinger zu fahren wir damals
von bäumen dauert halt jetzt nur 170 da
hinten ist eine wohnung im haus als er
sich für geil aus seit einer so gebaut
oder da ich weiß es nicht glaubt nicht
grün ist alles vom bruins mod sein
er hat doch selber gebaut das sonst wird
man den gang nach unten gewesen
ach so ja nach 90 meter
ich brauche aber ohne engagement ist es
war die ganze staffel nicht laufen wenn
statt des noch 42
aha sich die für geholt
160 sich schon die grundstücke bauer gut
ist doch schon mal was du hast wegens
überlebt ja da mache ich erstmal ganz
kurzen kaffeepause und ich so eiskalt
gestorben
denn wir haben noch ein bisschen zeit
zwei minuten erst 10 2 minuten sieben
minuten etwas längere folge haben die
fünf minuten scheiß drauf ich habe dich
lassen fünf minuten fahrzeugen leitung
wie du ja ja aber wie läuft der täter
wahrscheinlich auch über nacht ja auch
egal sonst nämlich jeder erfolgreichen
dienstag noch lange halten
ich hab hat colomba verwechselt spark
wollen wir unsere häuser unter experten
verbinden mit einem tunnel verbinden
ja und ethisch der so aus kommt glaube
ich nicht sie aussehen diese pipes
gemacht
darf ich vorstellen ich mache mir den
einen generator an den generator ziel
hatte ja und ich mach volksliedern
jackpot was bräuchte jetzt als ich
brauche auf jeden fall die drei hier so
schön habe ich schon auf die batterie
stimmt reisen und die kabel deutschland
auch nicht so
ach da kommt im goldrausch besser
scheißegal oder was denn ingrid wenn du
was machst batterie ja ja klar
ok bis jetzt habe ich eine batterie und
jetzt kommt mein generator
ja ich hab den generator wahr das hab
ich geschafft
unglaublich unglaublich
soweit ich das mal so glaube ich noch so
eine bet box hier generator was bräuchte
noch electric fördern oder warum ich den
mails raytracing electric furness habe
ich hier um stehen
feuerstein euch verstanden habe ich
maschinen blog dafür braucht man eine
menge wie viel habe ich dennoch von rief
1 1 gar nichts mehr cool elektronischer
elektronischer zirkus ja na gut ich
mache jetzt ganz kurzen tat dann würde
ich sagen
ja gut dann weißt du trotz kurzer pause
machen dann nämlich hat noch die letzten
minuten
deswegen würde ich erst mal sagen es
euch gefallen hat dürfte gerne einen
baum hoch geben oder halt in die
kommentare tipps et cetera schreiben bin
ich jetzt zwar noch nicht so drauf
eingegangen
aber ich habe hier schon eine mail von
toni und eine nachricht von einem
anderen typen wo mir ein paar sachen
erklärt werden allerdings wollte ich
jetzt halt erstmal das hier machen
deswegen macht das damit nächstes mal
dann würde ich sagen es gibt es nicht
sitte zwei krieg aber mein ex elektronen
elektro sachen durch die ihm helfen es
drei gräber lampe scheiße für hier
helfen
nein ich komme gleich hat mir gerade ein
scharfes schwert geholt warum warum
warum
alter ist schlagbar keinen mehr kein
krieg bei dir das ist echt so am haken
wenn das dann nicht mehr fahrbar
ach so wenig hatte auch gesagt wie das
klima ist explodiert oder was ich habe
dann aber geschlagen dass er weg
gegangen habe ich voll direkt bekommen
die kunden aber der ist da noch aber der
schein einen schlag folgen bekommen oder
warum hast du uns stopp weil dann könnte
ich doch eben hier die anderen häuser
hat kurz zeigen was man zeigt euch die
anhäuser kannst aber noch immer eine
aufnahme der golf workforce scheiße nein
ich glaube das wird ganz gut was dell
plant das so geht es dieser stelle
ok also ich hab ich hab's erst mal alles
hier verteidigen können wunderbar und
das was die luft geflogen ist vom 3
khalifa erzeugen kann nicht gemacht der
klammer vier folgen oder hochgeladen ja
ich glaube der hat auch irgendwie stress
oder so dass der gast braucht oder so
ähnlich aus einem grundstück hier so
dann geben wir weiter
ja ok den rest habt ihr eigentlich schon
gesehen weil ich da mal her gelaufen bin
also da hinten kämpft mit seiner
komischen maschine
und dann ist ja gut und hier kommt mein
haus hin also dass noch kein haus aber
da kommt auf jeden fall was hin und zwar
etwas kolossales läuft das was man
definiert nicht essen kann von überall
sehen kann bzw soll mit bloßer und lava
und irgendwie leichter arbeiten nicht
als es noch nicht genau es aber auf
jeden fall auf einer erhöhten position
okay dann würde ich erst mal sagen wie
immer
ich mach mir ein minütchen weiter